i'm exposing myself to homeless germs
anyway i might as well get a nut off
yeah
[Music]
what's up bros uh my name is stavros
halkis i got a special on youtube go
watch that bad boy but right now i'm
gonna answer the internet would you
rather lose half your dick's length or
half your dick's girth
i mean i'm killing myself instantly
but i can't i can't i can't i can't lose
a scintilla of either
[Laughter]
i'm barely hanging on
i guess if oof
dude that's a tough penis either way
anyway
my dig would be basically a twizzler at
this point if i lost half the girth
damn but i couldn't go all right let's
see let's do the math here i feel like
uh barely three inches regular girth
versus just a
just a a slim six
it's not what you want either way i
can't i'm sorry
would you rather be able to eat as much
as you want without getting fat or never
have to pay for any meals what the [ __ ]
is this
are you kidding me
i don't give a [ __ ] how much a meal cost
that even when i was poor that was never
a problem this is the easiest one anyone
has ever had to answer here
this would this would solve every
problem in my life
oh my god
would you rather eat all your food
through a straw or have all your food
tossed into your mouth
i'm gonna have to get on my seal [ __ ]
dude i'm have to have my [ __ ] open i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be like flipper
because there's no way i'm drinking a
[ __ ] korean barbecue smoothie you
know what i mean but i can catch some
bulgogi in my mouth no problem what was
better ages 8 to 18 or ages 18 to 28
i mean 18 to 20. i mean 8 18 there's the
there's the innocence it's pretty nice
whatever but there's also a lot of dog
[ __ ] years in there we were talking
middle school we're talking you know and
i didn't get [ __ ] until
much after 18. like like too long after
18. so i'm 18 to 28 was actually i had
some [ __ ] nice i had some i had some
toothless years in there
it was fun i i broke it on a chicken
wing that is the real story
mary [ __ ] killed gushers fruit by the
foot shark bites
oh now we're now we're this is tough
shark bites is definitely an underrated
classic i feel like having gushers and
shark bites is wrong
it's got to be [ __ ] gushers
because i don't i don't want a candy
busting in my mouth every time
that's when i'm feeling like a little
[ __ ] i'm having gushers so i'm gonna go
gushers go [ __ ] i'm putting on
lipstick and i'm i'm putting on my
cutest dress and i'm [ __ ] gushers
once a month you know but i'm marrying i
think i'm marrying shark bites yeah i'm
a shark bites guy
and uh fruit by the foot it's fine it's
fine
but i prefer my [ __ ] better than food
easily fruit roll up now we're getting
hot now it's harder would you rather
have a dog die every time you laugh or
have there be a genocide every time you
fall in love
[ __ ] dogs
dude
i mean they're cool and everything but
one yeah i mean i laugh a lot which is
tough i've been in love maybe like four
times that's that's a lot of ethnicities
we're wiping off the map
yeah yeah
uh dog the dogs are gonna have to take
one for the team i'm sorry would you
rather know when you're going to die or
how you're going to die i don't i don't
need this information man
i mean i guess when just for uh just for
budgeting purposes you know what i mean
if i find out i got seven years dude i'm
going to dubai tomorrow you know what i
mean i'm
i'd rather know when i'd rather know
when because i could really go well i
could really have a [ __ ] sick couple
years you had one free throw and if you
make it you get a million dollars but if
you miss you never get to text again oh
dude [ __ ] i don't need to text a million
dollars i'll go phone call i'll go
facetime i'll i'll take a picture
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm a phone call guy
would you rather give up porn or sex i
mean porn dude for one year
not even a [ __ ] question
i don't give a [ __ ] i'll beat off to my
imagination
that's kind of fun you know
i'll think about my [ __ ] sixth grade
biology teacher for a year
there are some good looking teachers and
it they're the one one of the ugliest
teachers in my high school had
truly a cartoonishly large ass that
would be funny just like i'm talking
like i'll be like this
and that would be pretty funny just to
feel
just i don't even think my dick could
get past an ass that big yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm still thinking i looked up on
facebook a couple years ago time hasn't
been nice to her but but i'm still in
there yeah yeah
would you rather your dick shed shed its
skin like a snake or have it rattle like
a rattlesnake every time you move
dick shed like i'm i got a fresh i got
fresh dick skin every month
it's shining dude
my dick looks like a [ __ ]
fresh like a newborn baby every month i
love that dude i could use a new skin
dude
give me some of that bar stool face
cream i'm gonna put it on my dick
would you rather never have any buffalo
sauce food again or only be able to
masturbate to pregnant porn now i can
have wings that just can't be buffalo
style correct see because of the
advancement in sauce technology over the
last decade or so this is just too easy
and here's the thing i don't even mind
pregnant porn
if this was if this was wings all wings
versus pregnant porn pregnant porn in a
in a walk but
i like a garlic parm wing i like a a
mango you know what i mean what could
you do longer hold your breath
underwater or have sober sex sober sex
oh yeah i can't hold him i have bad
lungs i have asthma and i'm a sober sex
haver too i don't get you know that's i
think that's that is youth but i also i
never needed obstacles for my penis so
eight whiskey sodas was it was always an
issue like that was that was tough for
me so i like to go sober anyway are
there sacred days when you refuse to
masturbate funerals tragedies
religious holidays
no what the [ __ ]
i was in seventh grade i would have i
mean if if somebody i'll put it this way
i don't think i did but if on the if on
the somber
bus ride home
a woman showed me her breasts i would
have you know what i mean if
there were if there was like extenuating
circumstances if the wind blew me even
one [ __ ] millimeter over to getting
to jacking off i would be there you know
yeah for sure all right who wouldn't
fight 10 10 year olds or 100 100 year
olds would the kids be tuckered out and
then when we say win is this to the
death
note to the death
i think that i think some nice grandmas
could trick children eating poisoned
brownies and i think they could also
guilt them now if in one of these 10 you
have like a little sociopath it's done
yeah please
i love you sonny and then just stabs him
i think you could i think i think we've
got a wily hundred year olds and i think
this is some ageism right here
would you rather watch your dad [ __ ] a
100 year old man or your mom murder
somebody oh
it would be hilarious to watch my dad
[ __ ] old guy
i think it would see it would be cool to
watch my mom kill something like
especially if they deserved it yeah but
if the damage it would do to my mom
psychologically yeah i don't i want to
shield her from that and if all my dad
has to do is [ __ ] some old guy and i'm
laughing thinking about it like
would you rather get projectile vomited
on by a homeless person for an hour
straight or get your dick sucked by a
toothless homeless person with no gag
reflex yeah this is interesting so i'm
trying again i'm trying to do the math
here about why i wouldn't get my dick
sized
diseases maybe
a rotted out mouth
i'm exposing myself to homeless
germs anyway i might as well get a nut
off yeah
[Laughter]
whistle pig piggy back is aged six years
it is 100 rye whiskey the first one it's
perfect for sipping it's perfect for
mixing it's perfect for absolutely
everything it's perfect for shooting
sipping flasks do whatever you want with
it it's armstrong whiskey it's delicious
go to
whistlebigwhiskey.com or any local store
retailer and get yours right now i
highly recommend it
make sure you subscribe to kfc radio on
youtube to get all the video content uh
subscribe comment like and make sure you
turn on the bell notifications so you
know whenever new video content drops i
want to say something but the videos